this is a production of cornell
university
so sit back relax but it's going to be
full packed and i will help you to
unpack
so this
30-40 minutes i'm going to walk you
through the context of cgir
you know now it's going through the 1cz
consolidation almost replicating exactly
the big
multinational egg company
uh the big six all right
and the
second part i'm going to walk you
through some survey results some
analysis and the mba
tools concepts are applied to it and
including the guide for analysis
and also the root cause analysis and at
the end i will try
to give some recommendations
cgir
most of you in the room also on the line
i think you're familiar with cgir if
you're not
basically
it's the green revolution and also you
know
uh burlock right
so
for the
is technology innovation and its
adoption it's great success story and on
left hand side you can see
just the wheat the yield increase that's
really changed
agriculture
i would say at least from the 60s
to 80s
and also
as part of the green revolution the
other product is the forming of cgiar
and you can see
the funding for
the funding for you know
is a symmet
it's an erie ita and a c ad and later
with the success we have the first
expansion and we have the second
expansion so there was 18 and later
consolidated into 15.
so why one cd
after six years great glory and such
huge impact and why now
from this figure you can tell
from this
72 all the way to 2017
the funding
actually going all the way up all the
way to 2014 but since then dramatically
going down
and especially in kobe time
is another 10 percent
so cgir cciar together how to really
work together
to read brand
the offering to be competitive
so this
has a lot of economic drivers
so i did a picture analysis basically
policy environmental technology etc but
is one single factor for the simplicity
is economic factor
so right now you can see this is from
the cg website
the overall funding steadily declining
since 2014 it's almost a 30
reduction
and you can tell why
because the public
reading the funding from the
high-income countries as previous slides
showed
is shifting
it's outgoing to private industry and
funding for example vertical farming
right
and for low-income countries
the state owned
agriculture is really prospering they
are delivering the local needs so why we
need this international agriculture
organization
so for five consecutive years you can
see the double digit deficits
and to overcome this deficit
that's why consolidating into one
how about
the digital transformation project here
give you a little bit of context
in these past 10 years
started with a breeding management
system as part of the integrated reading
platform
that was funded by gays had a greatest
success
and the second round we had a breed base
that's for the next generation cassava
and extended to other root tuber banana
crops
and later we had almost concurrent
reading for rice
and also
gobi genomic open source of breeding
informatics
and soon after that
we had enterprise breeding system ebs
and this is supposed to be
crop agnostic
and it's supposed to be really
easy to scale and local to maintain and
this is grand region
and iso 21
breeding for rice and gobi are folded
into ebs so the current state is ebs
free base and bms these three large
digital transformation projects are
concurrent
so
this mba project is a real-time
management consulting
i was passionate trying to solve
worse actual goals
so why our funder investors investing so
much
on the digital transformation project
what kind of values they deliver are we
learning it
and
if not
what are the reasons
so
i interviewed and also surveyed the
digital transformation project out of
previous several projects directors
adoption leads and some informal and
some formal
and here are based on the directors
answers and discussions
so please take this as the face value
they are not comparable
but this is just the first step help us
to put some quantitative numbers
all right
so you can see
we are i would say divided into
three type of products
if you call this project deliver
products also deliver services so three
type of products the first type is
managing reading data
okay
and the second type is the genotyping
data
and the third one is more like market
segments if you are looking at
any kind of crop species
versus very specialty crop is more like
a root tube of banana
so from this you can see
the value proposition the ebs and the
bmis
very similar they all target into very
generic any kind of prop species
no differentiation from each other these
two okay for the same goals
and the kobe is very unique it was
funded to manage genotyping data it was
never supposed to serve directly the
breeding data breeding process
however
gobi
does have
the
the decisions the party used genotype
data and a brief base
is mainly for serving the root tuber of
banana crops all right and the beef
wires
mainly for rice so from this table you
can see the p
information you need to look at is
the total investment and also the
investment used for uh development
all right so these are numbers from the
directors
and also the current percentage of
completion based on the origin of the
target
and the next one is the
number of users so the users all depends
on
different systems they say how many
people logged in and could be somewhere
active users or maybe somebody just
started logging in for example for ebs
and then the percentage is the adoption
rate okay the adoption rate depends on
the original targeted total how many
users will be in this
and another index we can look at is the
productivity index so productivity index
is a total what percentage completed and
over how long
and also how much spent on it it's just
a way to help us to look at it
any questions before i go to the next
slide
okay so if not here the current state
based on just
the positioning for these products
i would say uh there are many ways this
is just a simply way to look at it
internal handling uh breeding data or
genotyping data is the x axis and the
y-axis is looking at do you have
integrated data analysis support
capability as of now
april 2022 okay
and you can see a kobe yeah very much
focused on genotyping and also how
market system selection genomic
selection is uh outside the major data
management systems
and the bmi spree based ebs these three
are intended to have its own data
analytics diseases support but as of it
is a brief base where kernels has some
genomic selection pipeline built in and
the bms can also handle low heat density
markers
and the ebs and qobi
is uh already integrated into ebs as it
is mainly focusing on the phenotyping
and before orange design has the sample
trikey but not
much the genotyping
all right so another way to look at it
is invite in order to evaluate the
success of these digital information
projects is where they are in terms of
adoption right that's always here if you
hold the product how the user using it
and also who developed it because who
developed versus
the adoption is very much dependent
on the ownership that's why
if it developed outside of the cgir
they really
mark very much a buy-in so this is the
current
map so you can see ebs people are mainly
owned from development also adoption
they have great competitive advantage on
the right top quadrant
and bmis rebased gobi the development
team were outside the cg
all right
and uh
in terms of adoption
there is other strategy is a sponsor
from higher up versus really
the bottom up there's different adoption
advantages as well
so as of now
on the left hand side you can see
any kind of product on the market i'll
go through r d development and it's
going through some early testing until
you have early adopter introduction and
eventually you go through the growth and
maturity and decline this is for seeds
and for electronics for any kind of
products and on the right hand side is
from the mit summary based on industry
all kinds of digital transformation
products you need to go through this
design and you really need to continue
involve
invest until this goes through the
deployment until the stable
and finally can emerge
almost under the water emerge after a
few years and going through this feature
enhancement user feedback can go through
improve
and among this
it can be shorter like three years can
be longer all depends on yeah how ideal
this process can be right so the key
message here is the break-even points
so in order to invest in these digital
transformation projects as our funding
donors we need to
be aware there is the regular life cycle
regardless how hard
how good
the the project management all right so
as of 2020 to april that's what we see
brief-based bmis
almost got to the meeting the user's
stakeholders expectation stage so at
this stage once users started adopting
they call that transformation and gobi
basically already wrote into ebs before
even come up to the service level all
right
all right license learn this based on
the interview and on the left-hand side
i think very much my chain based
hardware business review what we see
four points to summarize from this
director's
feedback is
the most critical the most critical we
cannot emphasize more if you really how
the people on your team
that's depends basically they determine
everything if you do not have the right
people in leading the technology
leading the adoption leading the
strategy
there's you do not have the vital
proposition to say you will have a
successful project the second one is
partnership
if you go along
you go faster
if you go together you go further
repeatedly from interview we see this
third one is very critical we learned
you really need to quick turn around you
really maintain very transparent
intimate customer relationship you can
be late right when you go to the airline
you found that you're three hours late
if the airline company people never talk
to you you're mad right
but if they come out like in you're in
japan they give you tea
and they give you snacks they talk to
you they keep on updating you when's
next flight you're happy right you
partner with the
owner
exactly faster around and maintain
transparent intimate customer
relationships last one the most
important that's where we are now
is
breeding champions you need to hold
underground breeding champions work with
you
you really need to have the senior
leadership from the institution sponsor
you
and you need to have the investors
behind you
because for all these digital
transformation projects it's almost like
a business to business kind of business
model there need to be commitments there
need to be contracts top down bottom up
if you miss one
it's not going to get you there all
right so grid license learn
so after seeing the
survey results and also the license
license learn now let's go to the next
step
the next step is where i did a deep
analysis i tried to think during this
mba consulting project is
what aren't your funders goals what are
their strategies so why these projects
were funded right over and over together
72 million in the last seven uh 10 years
so this we can see
actually is really about
fast variety turnaround
right
and it's really improved productivity
the quality
managing breeding
because non-profit or cgir
want to replicate these large
multinational agricultural companies
will we have what we do not have
right we have great scientists
and from one stage to another stage to
another stage can we manage this
breeding cycle hand off
the product to the next stage gate
as productively as our counterpart
that's what the funders think
we are in the position without the
technology and we can
so that's the origin of goals that's why
the investment we are able to say we are
competitive
however here as my analysis is
by each bucket which each stage we are
doing just fine however the red arrow is
this is integrated
business value chain there is a gap
for our systems
for our people for our process
we have too many transaction costs we
are not able to
fast turn around
and
to capitalize
what's already been delivered from the
previous value chain
and we are not able to go through this
fast recycling
quickly make a decision to feedback to
improve this continuously
so this
this is violating gap between the
current state and future state where we
want to be next one
in terms of the capabilities
the boxes highlighted in yellow
looking at all these digital
transformation systems currently
we can ask ourselves
do we have the functionality
do we have the capabilities
is that easy enough to manage the
business rule and processes pipelines to
enable the optimized
the product handoff
so this is my self-assessment
as a
reading i would say domain expert from
industry and also 20 years and that's
what i see
we have a lot of
tools definitely however the area
highlighted in yellow
they are not integrated so the process
there's disconnect and that's the thing
preventing us from being able to meet
funders goals
you understand those
and also the gap
this is one way of to look at
root causes so group houses there are
different tools this is one too called
congruence model congruence model
basically is you have very solid
strategy
we do have solid strategy right in the
cgir all these years for every digital
transformation project however
you put all the contributing factors in
the same pockets so we put them in the
works what the goals what we need to do
and once the people right that's what we
already see the key competency in the
project and what kind of structures
enabling the people to accomplish the
goals the work right and also the
culture
so with the input
we evaluate
do we have the desirable output outcome
if they do not align or matching with
your expectation
then you'll dive down into each of the
buckets
and find where's your route cost
okay given time
i'm going to
give it
a little bit of the hint okay
we have great people
and we have great a
business analyst
and so many example data process
business use
however to me the funders those we saw
the outputs were not there yet
i would say the major major root cause
if lease of course can help us to think
i will
read to
uh you
so jack welch the former ceo right
the ge
is a great use case for us to learn
about leadership he says an
organization's capability to learn and
translate that learning into action
rapidly is the ultimate competitive
advantage
there is much with our license learned
from the directors you need to be ideal
you need to be quick adapt and learn
it's okay you do not have the technology
but you have the people you have the
culture to learn
so great leader under his assault
leadership simon sinek
he says true human leadership protects
an organization from the internal
rivalries that can shatter a culture
when we have to protect ourselves from
each other
the whole organization suffers
but when trust and corporations thrive
internally we pull together
and the organization grows as strong as
a result
i will leave these two codes
for us to
meditate
all right transition to the last part
we talked about the cg the driving
factor
as economics we talked about
the survey the results analysis and we
did the
current state and future state there is
a gap and
in the root cause
this is my recommendation so
immediate
uh problems the immediate problem is you
have bmis free base ebs three concurrent
systems
if the funders want to retire some
i'll keep all
of deciding what we need to do
or from different institutes we already
started adopting
but not a complete layer
how do we want to make these decisions
this can be very generic just simple
checklist ask these questions
is the system routinely used to manage
the critical operations
if yes
yeah you need to keep it
is the system hosting large amount of
data processes
if yes
you need to keep it can the new system
replace the existing capabilities
back then i said that if no
of course right
if it's a yes then you're sensitive but
i would say
there's also transaction costs think
about it you change your cell phone plan
your provider for your tv program right
it's not so easy even you have a new
system
with the same existing capabilities so
here is
yeah but this is a simple way if you
want to put a binary kind of answer
will many a client impacted upstream
downstream
if this existing platform no longer
maintained
i know you know how the user institute
is going to fight with you
nails and tooth if you
if they're impacted so maintain yes no
and with the new system right it should
meet a similar needs right
there's a much question you need to ask
it's a new system low cost to maintain
is that going to cause critical process
to break even no longer maintain
so at least some simple questions we can
ask ourselves
for managers for funders so the decision
yeah can be huge cost so let's take
educated
uh risk uh take informative risk instead
of a small base of emotion
based on just short-term
benefits
next one
think about you are trying to think
about which one to keep to maintain
and also where the current
adoption map
can we safely project three years from
now
22
23 24
for these three systems
bms free-based ebs where they be
so ebs may need another two to three
years finish the development
until it can be stabilized for my user
feedback
freebase bms currently already have a
lot of users as the early matrix you
showed right 800
people already logged in
of course you also saw the gap in term
managing the current processes
the genomic selection market system
selection multi-child analysis all that
when users using it they will be able to
give it a feedback so in the next three
years super super critical for all these
three systems
work really intimately with the
customers so you drill the adoption
once you show the adoption your product
will be improved okay
if you hold back
not being transparent it will keep you
even further behind
recommendations for the big picture
problems
so this will
get you the i would say
how do we manage the performance do we
want to wait until say millions dollars
spend several years spent then we start
evaluating and look back
or we can
very transparent manage this so one two
from
uh the mba
work is called a balanced stocks
scorecard okay there are
four buckets is very important
when we talk about root causes in the
congruence model how do you manage the
people side
the work side the structure side and
also the culture side i know it's very
small for you to really
the people side is all about how do we
satisfy
our funders our customers our key
stakeholders right
managing is how do they look
to research providers
and including
our employees the developers right the
business analyst
so all these people how do we
really
keep them happy
and what can we measure on regular basis
of course uh this cost benefits ratio
actually saw 10 to one
and the file to earn a result and the
product leadership the customer how do
customers see us how do we see ourselves
can be very different story from how our
customers see us
so at least the
in the column in the measures a few
kpis you can use
an internal learning growth as the code
says an organization how do we manage
our growth mind and keep learning
we may know how to answer
but if we have this culture
to incentivize people to learn to grow
we will have success
the last piece is the internal process
how do we make decisions
how do we
manage risk
all right this is just different way to
say
we have great opportunities coming the
risk looking at the full bucket all
these questions the
first one you start with financial
stewardship
okay then you go down to the
internal process
and then you will manage your learning
get things done
and you will be able to really help
create a customer relationship
so if you do not start
with this very fast learning ideal
process
that will be difficult
all right quick summary
so after walking through the broader
context
we see the director's survey
we see there's great opportunity the
last 10 years digital transformation
did bring us to a tipping point the
tipping point is twenty percent versus
eighty percent
we are not as five years ten years ago
you have to persuade someone to adopt
they are ready to adopt our breeding
programs it's up to us so we how these
breeding champions
okay so our gap our root causes let's
ask us are we ideal enough to learn
are we transparent enough to engage our
customers to do it together partner with
us
are they engaging our other in this
digital ecosystem the partners for
example the upcoming robbie hackathon
together solve the problem communicate
in the same language
that's the first step to start solving
the problems
so the product the services itself
is solvable
and the key whole message here is let us
create a culture
and held digital leadership
with that i'm going to open up
for the questions
but before you ask the questions i would
like i'd like to acknowledge
the sponsors this project sponsored by
yung hwa
and supported by kylie and our funder
gary
and the contributors from the digital
transformation project directors and
coaches and consultants from my mba
program adopting
overlaying these
mda framework tools
into this use case
and
well you are thinking about the
questions on the line and also in the
room i'm going to give you the third
person okay ready
northeast iowa
i felt that families on the lands needed
help from scientists and i dedicated my
life to science
so in other words people who bothered
the room
the last person brought me to
this
seminar completely volunteer
scientist
i think many of us work
in other cultures
without the same culture
has basically so little technology
it can triple quadruple the yield of
fleas
they are able to get a variety
to the farmer's field
by weekend
to change
he became obsolete
is this the destiny of the human species
all right
so
please
welcome any question if you wish you
have time
okay from gary
yes is gobi really incorporated into evs
it would be good to hear the status of
that integration
yes
thank you gary
a lot of background work
has been done gary
in terms of front end i think uh is
leadership discussion i think decision
and kobe not only how the
data management
piece
also have the market system selection qc
and genomic selection is independent
tools so well ebs is building these
integrated analytics decisions apart
i think in the next several years
our
users
will be good they see what's the current
state of these
existing capabilities developed by the
past
six seven years of gobi team and also
the cg partners
okay kelly
so you may have to repeat my question i
guess
but
you mentioned this is kind of a
start of looking at this landscape and
and
uh
you know making the future playing um
i do think there's a need to learn from
the lessons of these projects um and i'm
not sure that that will get incorporated
back in in terms of strategy so what are
the next steps here you mentioned this
disciplinary data it was going to carry
forward into a more
in-depth analysis uh on how to invest in
the state
yeah so for people on the line kylie's
uh comments or question is
this what i just presented is create a
first step
and what are the follow-up basically how
do we incorporate the license learn
here are my thoughts
i took on this because i generally just
interested in
this solvable problem
since in the room
also people on the line we really how
the key decision makers
if you see this provide a value for us
to get into the second phase
yeah let's do that i'll be very happy
to apply what i learned and we can even
um work with the johnson school with the
smith school get consultants a lot of
them want to do this
just as a free consulting including
myself we truly think this high impact
if we can work through this in a second
stage
based on license learn i think that will
be huge
yeah
thanks kelly yes jean-luc
it seems like one of the problems in go
i mean like so so to me the main problem
that that you were seeking to present
was
we have these three systems ebs bms free
base
and how do we decide to move forward
with one of these three i mean that's
sort of the lens that i was looking at
here and it seems like an issue is that
it's very hard to come by unbiased
opinions
about this because whoever uses the
system likes that system and so they're
going to tell the johnson school this is
the good system right and and
and i you know i mean
so i i don't know i i mean
and part of i feel like kelly once said
when kelly says what are the lessons
learned is like this is a very difficult
thing to do like developing software i
think everybody in this room realizes
developing software that helps breeders
is actually hugely challenging
right
and uh
and so there's but yet humans are always
hugely optimistic so there's always
somebody who comes along i think that
johnny come lately in this story is ebs
who thinks oh i can do better than
people who came before so i'm going to
start something new
and uh
and that's just going to happen over and
over i mean it's like learning the
lessons of human nature
because yeah i don't know so i don't
have a good question in this but
it would be it would be a great a great
project but it but it seems like it
would be what like
you would have to find people who have
no emotions
practically who can assess these systems
objectively and i just don't know where
to find those people
yeah so look
for people on the line john luke's
comments
yeah this is kind of a digital
transformation project for example
goldbe right but you can all have biases
and depends on the users you already got
used to
and you will
you will fight for tooth and nails
basically because a huge trans
transaction costs to move from one
system to another and you do not know
how well so john luke's comment is how
can we
find someone you will remove that
buyer's emotional factors and this is
really challenging problem right
otherwise there is always another new
project idea a new group thing they can
do better and you have this going in
cycle cycle yeah all right so
jungkook i don't think i have a good
answer but i would just say uh
thinking about
in a
big
multinational company right
in big multinational company it's very
much top and down
leave your set of budget this kind of
strategic initiative right a few and
they can do
cross saucy from internal external light
tube like r d validate
and after a few years if it is not
profitable yeah this basically just goes
inside or maybe just kill it
so for us
i think it's very important
the evaluation managing this
how well we are doing what we're doing
well not doing what's learning in a
process very transparent not by emotions
because all the people in these projects
we are very much invested in
and it's not really the tools the system
good and now good
it's developers time label fi i didn't
present that the profile analysis by the
i.t project directors by funders by the
directors by the
developers everyone
there's something drive them in changing
motivation some reward right
so
the the key part is people have to talk
to each other how to talk to each other
and then
what makes this structure kind of work
is
you do not want to go through this uh
commercial term called a
canopolization
what we did in these 10 years exactly
canon violinization basically
you launch your own product and you will
kill your own product you launch it
again you kill it and each the customers
when they see this new product
they already adopted right
and a new product coming they compete
with each other and this is not going to
have any product to be a dominant
product
and then for these
the market the segment analysis that we
see
through tuber fernando crops they will
have our different needs from inbred
crops hybrid crops
and there's a lot that doesn't fit
directly but the foundation is okay
and it's flexible enough that it doesn't
make those types of us assumptions about
infrared or
you know and we're working with also
clonal crops which have a very different
lifestyle so
i guess
my question is like are those divisions
really just artificial ways to keep them
alive or are they actually
important distinctions
yeah
i mean
if i get if i get you in my two cents on
this question and this is just like you
know the famous story of the seven blind
people and the elephant right
this problem is definitely an elephant
and we're definitely all blind and so am
i
but
but like
you you put the you put breed base into
this root tuber banana little
little box when it can actually be used
uh you know agnostic to to breeding
system i mean we use it for sugar kelp
which is you know has haploid
individuals and diploid individuals so
so in some ways though i mean part of
the part of the emotional bias that
happens here is the sunken
sunken cost fallacy right
each of these breeding management
systems has a ton of sunken costs in
them and we just hate to kill it because
we've already put so much into it but
you know in this sense you know breed
base is really threatening because
lots of people are using it
and uh it hasn't actually cost a ton of
money
it's pretty nimble i mean i mean i'm i'm
i'm here i mean i think lucas is
listening he's probably smiling from ear
to ear right
because i'm presenting a
a point of view of a biased point of
view that's very pretty much in favor of
rebase but
but if you just decide breed base could
be used by anybody as opposed to
relegating it to this rtb box
then all of a sudden it's pretty
threatening to bms and and and abs right
and i'm not sure it deserves to be in
that box because actually it's not in
that box in fact i mean i'm not saying
it's great like there's i know i know
lots of developers really don't like
this the underlying scheme
i won't name any names although it's
pretty obvious who they might be
but but you know i mean they've done
something right um because because
otherwise you wouldn't i mean like you
were very truthful in sort of showing
that there was a certain extent a
ground-up
adoption of breed base and not a
top-down nobody i mean like well some of
the people are using it more or less
being forced to use it but there are
plenty of others who have adopted it
without being forced to use it
uh which is says something you know
so so so you know i loved your answer
where you said
you know company they would just see if
a product is making money
and if it wasn't after a couple of years
and trying to recover the situation
they'd kill it right
and the problem is it's really unclear
how you how you figure out whether any
of these breed management systems is
quote unquote making money
when you have all of these different
ways that people are forced to or or not
adopted and so on
yeah thank you john look i hope people
on the line heard of john luke's porn
jungle is trying to help rebates okay
yeah if you didn't hear it yeah so just
quickly answer your question also mara's
comments about uh problem nothing maybe
the newer project doing better job
i i would say uh
for
reading management systems we are not
only managing the data
we are not only
managing the
the decision
we also managing the business rules
and the processes
it's so important if you see this uh
cycle
uh there's a product development cycle
for any varieties right you go through
this cycle from pre-breeding this media
characterization stage
basically whatever you have a a bag of
seeds you do not care about fixation
right that's very similar like a
bluetooth banana colonial crops but for
inside hybrid crops the process to
manage the product versus you go through
this entire development cycle six to
eight years at the end you do not want
to say i found it but i cannot give to
the farmers make this as a product
because you will have a mixed bag of
you call that accessions so you manage
the process for inbred for hybrid it's a
completely different story
you will not only just say i have the
data stored and i'm able to see like
whatever you select can you scale right
can you plant two acres they give the
exact same thing
and
to manage inbred how you do the variety
development variety evaluation and the
launch increase the seeds
in terms of sea system go through that
so much simpler than hybrid crops hybrid
crop you have to manage different
apparents right and go through this
tyson and selecting the inbred
with colonial crop every year
how many plants you need to plant to
evaluate after how many generations
completely different process completely
different decision making
cannot simplify this modern you how to
really understand the business in order
to develop the product the other product
service
so i would say
for us
you need to how the
community will practice truly kill you
be part of a development process you
develop features it's not going to
transfer in that into capability it's
not going to get you to go from the
pre-breeding all the way into what a
commercial company is able to say
in full five years you'll shorten the
cycle to deliver varieties that's a huge
mistake if you think
you can manage colonial crop the same
way as the breeding process decision
making process the seed production
process as inbred hybrid
sorry
[Laughter]
could i make a couple of
quick comments it's gary
oh yes please gary
yeah i just just two or three things um
one
one correction early on
uh uh starting to describe me as the
funder i'm not i work for the funder i'm
an employee
second is it's quite
uh
humbling to see all your
you know a whole bunch of your mistakes
on one slide
[Laughter]
the uh
third is i don't think we should frame
this problem anymore as which system
should we choose
um we've
you know the the problem is always being
how do we make
um public breeding programs more
effective
and efficient and the
the answer turns out not to have been we
build software for them
there's you know any of these systems
will work well uh there's off-the-shelf
commercial systems
prism would have worked fine we should
have bought that um
the uh
um for you know for this level of
program the question really is going
forward how do we
how do we
help these programs
um
modernize their processes deliver higher
rates of genetic gain and how do we
avoid over investing in in the
development of these software
uh tools i think it's really hard to say
what any one of them costs they're all
sort of subsidized in different ways
some are subsidized by um
you know the participation of people
whose uh a base funding comes from
another source some are subsidized
yes
directly by uh
uh
by grants you know um
and there's no doubt some of them have
been more efficient than others but
i you know
i don't think the question in front of
us is the big question is which system
do we use i think
at this point
and it would be great if uh we just
figured out how to you know
how to efficiently serve the users going
forward and minimize investment in
something that is not really
the core issue the delivering gains in
in farmer's fields
yeah yeah very true yeah i think that
discussion if several years ago yeah we
can talk about this and that
currently is really adoption
whatever we have i mean
if if i if i can contradict the funder
here
can you hear me hear me gary of course
i mean okay so so the question now is
adoption because we have a couple
systems that more or less work right but
until we had a couple systems that more
or less worked
the question wasn't adoption because
there wasn't anything to adopt
there was prism you know there was stuff
to buy okay okay okay so so maybe we
goofed there we should have just taken
what existed as opposed to funding a new
thing
uh
and then maybe things still need
development i mean there there are still
new methods coming online
there's there's all that that need that
need to be mirrored
in the software that supports them
so
so these things at this point i mean i
think they need to be swimming
so that they can
you know
uh have some user feedback i mean you
have to have users who are actually
using the thing to have user feedback
so that they can
then you know move on to the next sprint
or whatever it is
i'm not arguing that we shouldn't uh
continue to
improve
the tools that are available at the
moment though
um
that you know
these these tools are already pretty
good we need a
a
a better process for
a more efficient process for ensuring we
don't over invest
and we need to focus on
getting them used properly by the
breeding programs
that that
we're trying to support
i really like this discussion
and how about we take this offline i
will set up something to follow up with
the key stakeholders
and i think there will be a lot more
good ideas to manage maybe the second
stage of this analysis fill down the
license learn
yeah
and with that uh thank you everyone for
the 40-some people on the line and also
people in my room as a continuous thank
you thank you so much
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu